a massive document release overnight is
shedding new light on the 1963
assassination of President John F
Kennedy the National Archives put out
thousands of government files from one
of America's most traumatic periods at
the last minute President Trump said he
had to block the release of hundreds of
records the FBI and CIA claimed those
secret documents could pose a security
risk CBS News had a team up all night
reading the Declassified papers to see
what they reveal chip Reid is at the
National Archives in Washington with
what we have learned
chip good morning well good morning
according to a 1992 law last night at
midnight was the deadline for releasing
the last batch of documents pertaining
to the Kennedy assassination now some
documents have been withheld for now for
National Security Review but that still
leaves us tens of thousands of pages to
read what happened that November day in
Dallas still haunts the nation a young
president killed President Kennedy died
at 1:00 p.m. Central Standard Time
then the alleged assassin Lee Harvey
Oswald was killed two days later
stirring rumors of a conspiracy but the
newly released documents show the FBI
knew of a possible threat against Oswald
FBI director J Edgar Hoover wrote a memo
saying the night before Oswald was shot
a man called saying he was a member of a
committee organized to kill Oswald the
FBI reportedly contacted Dallas Police
who assured them adequate protection
would be given however this was not done
the FBI had actually been monitoring
Oswald's shooter Jack Ruby for a year
Hoover wrote that he was concerned about
conspiracies and wanted to have
something issued so we can convince the
public that Oswald is the real assassin
the FBI director also knew that Oswald
had ties to Cuba and Russia
Oswald was revealed to be on the FBI's
radar a month before the assassination
and he apparently told an associate that
he wanted to kill President Eisenhower
some information that came out after the
assassination one man told investigators
he heard a man betting $100 that Prez
Kennedy would be dead within three weeks
a 413 page memo details every threat
against Kennedy including those from the
Ku Klux Klan and some with mental
illness the documents also show that
both Russia and Cuba feared they would
be blamed and Russia worried that
Kennedy's death could possibly lead to
nuclear war experts on the Kennedy
assassination say there are so many
newly released documents and so many of
them are cryptic and almost impossible
to understand that it could be weeks
months or even years before we
understand their full significance and
even then they say we may never know the
whole truth
Charlie thanks chip